donc l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
des crédits de la mission sécurité et
article 46 TER et du compte spécial
contrôle de la circulation et du
stationnement routier du projet de loi
de finance pour 2023
est à Monsieur philippe Dominati
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues l'examen du budget de la
mission sécurité pour 2023 s'inscrit
dans un contexte qui pourrait appeler à
la nouveauté d'une part il s'agit du
premier budget du second quinquennat du
président Emmanuel Macron d'autre part
c'est également le premier budget de la
mise en œuvre des annonces faites dans
le cas du projet de loi locmic le
Parlement a examiné cet automne
pourtant on examinant précisément le
budget de la mission on constate avant
tout une forme de continuité
certes il y a des changements positifs
qu'il faut souligner globalement les
crédits de la mission sont ainsi en haut
et je m'en réjouis
prévoit d'ailleurs une hausse cumulée du
budget du ministère intérieur de 15
milliards d'euros entre 2023 et 2027 en
2023 pour ce qui concerne l'ensemble de
la mission sécurité la hausse des
crédits s'élèvent à un milliard 430
millions d'euros
on crée des paiement soit une hausse
d'un peu moins de 7% pour la police et
la gendarmerie nationale les crédits de
paiement sont en hausse de 1 milliard
globalement pour les programmes police
nationale et gendarmerie nationale les
dépenses hors titre 2 augmente quant à
elle de 2,1% en autorisation
d'engagement et 10% en crédit de
paiement en 2023 ces crédits sont
notamment dédiés à la modernisation
numérique et à l'équipement de la
gendarmerie de la police nationale c'est
une dynamique nécessaire
s'agissant du numérique il est notamment
prévu de développer les outils
numériques des forces de sécurité
intérieure afin d'améliorer leurs
conditions de travail et favoriser leur
présence et leur efficacité sur le
terrain
de renforcer les moyens de lutte contre
la cybercriminalité notamment en
augmentant le nombre de
cyberpatrouilleurs et il y aurait la
relation numérique avec les citoyens
par ailleurs l'équipement des policiers
gendarmes fait également l'objet
d'efforts pour assurer leur
parutionalité de nos forces et
accompagner les hausses défectifs sont
notamment prévu en 2023 le
renouvellement des équipements de
protection
d'intervention et de maintien de l'ordre
de l'habillement et des outils
technologiques de pointe je souligne
l'existence de la Coupe du monde de
rugby et la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques qui justifient aussi cet
effort sur l'équipement de nos forces
pour autant comme je le disais le
présent budget présente aussi des
caractéristiques de continuité
voire retombent dans certains travers
constatés par le passé ce que l'on peut
regretter
en premier lieu on constate une
stabilisation de la part des dépenses de
personnel dans l'ensemble des dépenses
de la police et de la gendarmerie en
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle d'autant
qu'une dynamique de baisse avait été
amorcée en 2021 comme je l'ai souvent
rappelé il est indispensable de réduire
la part des dépenses de personnel dans
l'ensemble des dépenses des deux forces
afin de dégager des marges de manœuvres
suffisantes pour l'équipement et
l'investissement
or il est souvent arrivé dans le passé
que les dépenses de personnel dérape au
détriment de l'investissement et des
dépenses de fonctionnement en 2023
83% des autorisations d'engagement et
86% des crédits de paiement seront
consacrés aux dépenses de personnel pour
ces deux forces c'est beaucoup
cette stabilisation de la part des
dépenses de personnel s'explique par le
fait que ces dernières augmentent de
5,8% pour les deux forces en 2022
cette hausse provient d'une part de la
poursuite de la politique de recrutement
comme vous le savez le président de la
République a créé plus de 10 000 emplois
de 2018 à 2022 alors que le plan de
création de poste était achevé la
première ministre et les diabète borne a
annonçant le 6 septembre 2022 la
création de 8500 postes de policiers
gendarmes d'ici à 2027 poursuivant ainsi
sur la lancée du quinquennat précédent
le projet de loi de finance pour 2023
prévoit ainsi la création de 2857 ETP
pour les deux forces dont 1907 pour la
police nationale les 950 pour la
gendarmerie nationale
or ces recrutement on est nécessairement
des conséquences financières notables en
outre en 2023 sera également marquée par
le coût lié à la revalorisation du point
d'indice de la fonction publique
intervenue le premier juillet 2023 2022
pardon pour un coup d'environ 170
millions d'euros pour les deux forces
enfin le poids de mesure catégorielles
atteindra en 2023 85 millions d'euros
pour la police nationale et 70 12
millions d'euros pour la gendarmerie
nationale
ce montant est en forte hausse du fait
des premières conséquences budgétaires
des deux protocoles conclu en mars 2022
en second lieu et c'est la deuxième
limite du présent budget les crédits de
la mission sont insatisfaisants
s'agissant de certaines dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'investissement le
risque est comme cela arrivait par le
passé qu'elle est sorti d'un plan
d'équipement porté cette fois par le
plan de relance les dépenses
d'investissement se tarissent et dans
une sorte de Stop and Go difficilement
soutenable
en particulier l'investissement dans
l'immobilier ne répond pas à la suite
des enjeux surtout pour la gendarmerie
nationale en effet les crédits
d'investissement portés par la mission
pour les locaux de la gendarmerie c'est
à dire principalement les casernes
sont en baisse de 42,5 millions d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement
il augmente que très modérément de 13,5
millions d'euros en crédit de paiement
globalement les crédits de paiement
s'établissent ainsi à 130 millions
d'euros en 2023 1300 millions d'euros à
comparer revers les réalisations
catégorienne que j'ai évoquée
précédemment sur les dépenses de
personnel le caractère modeste de cette
somme doit être soulignée d'autant plus
qu'à compter de 2023 les crédits du plan
de relance ne viennent plus apporter un
complément significatif comme cela avait
été le cas en 2021 et 2022
je rappelle que s'agissant de
l'immobilier l'effort doit être maintenu
sur la durée
je voulais je voudrais conclure mon
propos sur le sujet du compte
d'affectation spéciale radar et de la
politique de sécurité routière en 2021
année encore marqué par les restrictions
de déplacement dans le cadre de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire la
mortalité avait augmenté de par rapport
à 2020 de
3219 personnes ayant été tuées sur les
routes de France l'année dernière par
rapport à 2019 cependant année de
référence avant la pandémie la mortalité
avait diminué de 9% de et l'accès
identité de 4,5% que faire le bilan sur
les 7 premiers mois de 2022 présentent
quant à lui une augmentation de
mortalité routière par rapport à 2019
les recettes des crédits cases sont
quant à eux en hausse de 7% des dépenses
du casque comprendront notamment 200
millions pour la modernisation et la
maintenance
automatique au final j'ai émettrai un
avis favorable au nom de la commission
des finances sur les crédits de cette
merci la parole est à Jean-Pierre bogel
rapporteur spécial à la commission des
finances pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je souhaiterais tout
d'abord rendre hommage à l'ensemble des
sapeurs-pompiers des pilotes des
formations militaires de la sécurité
civile et des associations agréées qui
s'investissent sans compter dans la
lutte contre les crises qui touchent
notre pays comme nous l'avons de nouveau
constaté lors de cet été marqué par des
feux de forêt d'une ampleur quasi
inégalée c'est 510 ont rappelé à quel
point notre modèle de sécurité civile
doit être préservée je me félicite à cet
égard de la hausse importante des
crédits du budget du programme 161 pour
l'année 2023 je voudrais tout d'abord
m'attarder sur l'enjeu du soutien de
l'État en faveur S10 et plus
particulièrement sur la concrétisation
en 2023 des pactes capacitaires qui
permettront dans le cadre de
co-financement entre l'État et les
collectivités locales de soutenir sur
des projets d'investissement qui
bénéficieront aux 10 un montant initial
de 30 millions d'euros sur 5 ans devait
leur être consacrées ce qui apparaissait
particulièrement faible au regard des
besoins d'investissement
le gouvernement a toutefois procédé à un
renforcement bienvenu de cette dotation
en cours de navette en l'abondant d'un
montant de 150 millions d'euros donc
37,5 millions au titre de l'année 2023
président de la République à toutefois
indiqué dans le cadre de ces annonces du
28 octobre dernier que cette dotation de
150 millions d'euros s'inscrirait dans
le cadre de la compensation de la
suppression de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises
on ne peut donc pas présenter cette
enveloppe comme un véritable
renouvellement de l'effort de l'État en
faveur du financement des 10 puisqu'elle
consiste en réalité en une réaffectation
au 10 d'une recette qui bénéficier déjà
leur principaux financeurs à savoir les
collectivités locales
malgré cette réserve on ne peut que se
féliciter de la concrétisation de ces
PACS de capacités dans un contexte où
les 10 doivent investir massivement pour
se doter des moyens de faire face à
l'augmentation de leur sollicitations
opérationnelle
j'en viens maintenant à la question du
nécessaire renforcement de la flotte
aérienne de la sécurité civile ce projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 contient
plusieurs avancées à cet égard je me
félicite tout album du renouvellement et
de l'extension à venir de notre flotte
d'hélicoptère dragon vieillissante et
amputé ces dernières années de plusieurs
appareils à la suite d'accidents
tragiques
ce PLF concrétise ainsi la commande de
36 nouveaux appareils annoncés dans le
cadre de la Loch me et qui se
matérialise par l'engagement de près de
470 millions d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement
ces hélicoptères contrairement à ceux de
la flotte actuelle seront équipées d'une
capacité de largage d'eau importante et
pourront dès lors être utilement
mobilisés pour la lutte contre les feux
de forêt
le vieillissement de la flotte de
Canadair constitue également une source
de préoccupation partagée depuis
plusieurs années par les acteurs de la
sécurité civile les annonces formulées
par le Président de la République le 28
octobre dernier d'un renouvellement
intégral et d'une extension de cette
flotte ce sont traduites par un
amendement du Gouvernement visant à
financer une commande d'une douzaine
d'appareils cette commande est
évidemment bienvenue mais le calendrier
de livraison de ces canadairs suscite
des interrogations la chaîne de
production de ces avions à l'arrêt
depuis plusieurs années vient à peine
d'être lancée et les premiers appareils
ne pourront probablement pas être livrés
avant 2027 il est donc important que le
ministère d'intérieur
identifie d'autres pistes de
renforcement de la flotte à court terme
il me semble par ailleurs que l'enjeu du
renforcement des moyens aériens de la
sécurité civile ne peut être envisagée
sous le seul prisme capacitaire les
problématiques de prévention des feux de
forêt du dimensionnement des
infrastructures d'accueil des aéronefs
ou de la disponibilité des moyens
humains nécessaires au fonctionnement
opérationnels de la flotte doivent
également être prises en considération
or la direction générale de la sécurité
civile et notamment confrontée à de
grandes difficultés pour recruter et
fidéliser ces pilotes d'aéronef cette
profession souffre indéniablement d'un
déficit d'attractivité en moyenne un
pilote de la sécurité civile et trois
fois moins payée qu'un pilote de
l'aviation commerciale
le présent projet de loi de finances
prévoit certes des mesures de
revalorisation pour les personnels
navigants estimaient à un million et
demi d'euros mais je souhaiterais
également entendre madame la ministre
sur la stratégie envisagée par le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour pallier
ses difficultés de recrutement et
renforcer l'attractivité de la
profession de pilote de la sécurité
civile
je conclurai mon propos en évoquant le
projet de mutualisation des systèmes
d'information S10 Nexis 1812 les
nombreux retards dans le déploiement du
projet on conduit à entamer la confiance
de se disent dans sa concrétisation
cette situation fragilise la
modélisation économique de Nexis puisque
les 10 sont largement impliqués dans le
financement du programme par
l'intermédiaire de leur contribution
volontaire ces contributions devraient
être complétées par un soutien renforcé
de l'État en faveur de l'Agence du
numérique de la sécurité civile dont les
moyens sont aujourd'hui bien trop
faibles pour permettre le déploiement du
projet dans de bonnes conditions en
toute état de cause les investissements
consentis dans le cadre de ce budget
pour 2023 vont indéniablement dans le
bon sens pour cette raison chers
collègues je vous propose d'adopter les
crédits de la mission sécurité je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à madame Gisèle Jourda
rapporteur qui remplace Philippe Paul
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre chers collègues après
plusieurs années de progression des
crédits de la gendarmerie nationale du
notamment au plan de relance nous
pouvions craindre un retour de balancier
grâce à la programmation prévue dans le
cadre de la locmi ce n'est pas le cas
nous pouvons donc saluer les crédits
globalement en gros en 2023 passant de 9
milliards 3 à 9 milliards 9 en crédit de
paiement soit une hausse de
6,4%. en outre les effectifs
progresseront de 950 emplois permettant
la création de cet escadron de
gendarmerie mobile et le début de la
mise en place de 200 nouvelles brigades
territoriales celle-ci sera sans doute
vues comme un apport très utile dans
certains départements après des années
de suppression et de regroupement de
brigades lors de l'examen de la locmin
nous avions exprimé quelques
interrogations à ce sujet d'abord sur la
méthode concert avec les élus locaux là
c'est très vite avant même le vote de la
locmi nécessité d'avoir des critères
objectifs afin de garantir une
implantation durable et un réel effet
sur la délinquance préoccupation sur la
capacité des collectivités territoriales
à investir pour construire des locaux
outre les dispositifs de soutien déjà
existants à travers les décrets de 93 et
de 2016 la dotation d'équipements des
territoires ruraux a été évoqué ceci
existe déjà madame la ministre avez-vous
prévu des dispositifs supplémentaires
conformément à l'amendement adoptée par
le Sénat au sein du rapport annexé de la
Loomi d'autres aspects de ce budget
représente à notre sens un progrès
indéniable en particulier les 120
millions d'euros de crédit de paiement
pour la modernisation informatique et la
création d'une Agence du numérique des
forces de sécurité intérieure en 2019
nous avions eu des interrogations sur la
création de cette direction du numérique
au prix du secrétaire général du
ministère de l'Intérieur cette dune
devait plus ou moins absorber les
services d'information et de
communication des directions générales
de la police et de la gendarmerie et
notamment le service des technologies de
sécurité intérieure sts2 qui avait fait
ses preuves à travers néo ou Agora
soldes pouvez-vous nous confirmer madame
la ministre que la nouvelle agence du
numérique sera bien construite à partir
du stj2 mais avec davantage de moyen
pour le reste le budget du programme 152
pour 2023 affiche une certaine
stagnation des crédits hors titre 2
après plusieurs années d'effort dans ce
domaine s'agissant de l'investissement
immobilier la locmi a prévu la mise en
place d'un nouveau service chargé de
planifier les nouvelles constructions et
la maintenance lourde selon un
échéancier qui reste à élaborer sachez
que nous y serons extrêmement attentifs
en conclusion le budget de la
gendarmerie nationale pour 2023 affiche
merci monsieur le président
comme précédemment par mon corps
rapporteur le budget de la gendarmerie
pour 2023 comporte plusieurs aspects
positifs notamment les moyens importants
investis dans la transformation
numérique ceci permettront de poursuivre
la modernisation de la gendarmerie en
mettant en oeuvre les nouvelles étapes
de Néo ou encore du système PC Storm qui
constitue une brique essentielle du
réseau radio du futur tous ces nouveaux
systèmes numériques génèrent logiquement
des dépenses récurrentes de maintien en
conditions opérationnelles et de
renouvellement des équipements ceux-ci
montre une fois de plus l'importance de
la programmation plurielle difficile de
tout financer à la fois mais il ne faut
pas laisser se dégrader un aspect
pendant que l'on renforce l’autre
développer les meilleurs outils
numériques c'est bien mais si
parallèlement les gendarmes exerce dans
des brigades décrépies et sont logés
dans des carrières de dégradées ces
problématiques et inacceptables or la
lobby n'a pas prévu de programmation des
investissements
permettant honoré médié à ses points
noirs bien connus une fois de plus les
investissements prévus pour l'immobilier
au sein du programme 152 seront
insuffisants en 2023 d'un montant de 126
millions d'euros on est loin des 300
millions annuels nécessaires l'année
dernière un effort avait pourtant été
accompli pour passer de 100 millions
d'euros à 150 millions on revient donc
en arrière le Sénat adopté notre
amendement au sein du rapport annexé de
la Love Me prévoyant ce nécessaire
investissement de 300 millions d'euros
annuels dans l'immobilier domaniale quel
est votre intention madame la ministre
s'agissant de la mise en oeuvre de cette
disposition pour 2023 mais aussi pour
les années suivantes en ce qui concerne
les véhicules un renouvellement de 2000
unités seulement est prévue pour 2023
chiffres le plus bas depuis 2014 il est
vrai qu'un effort important avait été
conscience sentie de 2020 2022 avait
plus de 300 de 3500 ridicule par an ce
qui a permis de rajeunir un peu le parc
or là nous avons besoin d'une stabilité
et de la plurianualité indispensable
pour maintenir les forts afin d'avoir un
parc de véhicules léger qui reste en bon
état au fil du temps et non des périodes
face qui alternent avec des périodes où
l'état des véhicules est indigne en 2023
nous serons en tout cas bien en dessous
du renouvellement annuel de 10% du parc
pourtant inscrit dans le rapport annexé
de la Loomi je terminerai cependant par
un point positif en évoquant la réserve
opérationnelle de la gendarmerie la
locmi prévoit le passage de 30 000 à
50000 réservistes
objectif qui paraissait ambitieux compte
tenu de la stagnation des crédits au
cours des dernières années or on observe
bien au sein du programme 152 pour 2023
une hausse de 20% des crédits fléchés
vers la réserve se donne où nous
félicitons la progression significative
des crédits du programme 152 à conduit
notre commission à leur donner un avis
favorable même si nous garderons à
l'esprit certains points négatifs dont
en particulier la poursuite du
sous-investissement dans l'immobilier
auquel il faudra impérativement remédier
dans les prochaines années je vous
remercie
Leroy rapporteur pour avide la
commission des lois pour 3 minutes
je suis le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la commission des
lois a donné un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de la mission
sécurité en effet ce projet de loi de
finance fait en effet en effet pardon
ensuite à plusieurs années fait suite à
plusieurs années de large concertation
avec les laboration du Livre blanc pour
la sécurité intérieure et la tenue du
bobo de sécurité un projet de l'OPI
ensuite été élaboré répondant ainsi à
une de nos anciennes recommandations ce
projet porte plusieurs
portes des ambitions programmées qui
forment sur le but pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur
puisque ce ne sont pas moins de 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qui
seraient budgétés sur cinq ans par
rapport au crédit affecté au ministère
tant les dépenses de personnel que le
fonctionnement et d'investissement
augmente en 2023 s'occupe permettra de
financer les priorités fixées par le
projet de la Commission à toutefois
assortie de trois réserves son avis
favorables à l'adoption des crédits le
premier est dans l'exécution du budget
2023 celui de l'inflation la locmin a
été élaborée avant la survillance de ce
phénomène qui n'a pas conduit à
revaloriser les budgets dictés
la police et la gendarmerie nationale
vont donc devoir participer à des formes
nationales de rationalisation des
dépenses mais cela ne devra pas porter
préjudice à la capacité des forces à
faire face aux échéances de 2023 et 2024
le deuxième et le fait que le doublement
des effectifs sur la voie publique
n'aura 2 sens que si les effectifs du
service judiciaire qui traitent les
enquêtes et ceux des juridictions sont
augmentés de manière proportionnelle
sans cela c'est toute la chaîne pénale
qui sera engorgée sans amélioration de
la réponse pénale bien au contraire
enfin le troisième est celui de l'initié
la nécessaire diminution de la part des
dépenses de personnel de personnels dans
les dépenses totales de ces deux
programmes car après deux années de
diminution nette cette tendance est
moins claire en 2023 une évolution
structurelle est nécessaire
et la commission des lois s'y montrera
attentive je vous remercie merci chers
collègues
la parole est à Françoise Dumont
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
Michel collègue la commission des lois a
donné un avis favorable à l'adoption du
programme 161 relatif au moyen nationaux
de la sécurité civile nous saluons là
aussi significatif tant des
autorisations d'engagement qui dépassent
pour la première fois le milliard
d'euros que des crédits de paiement ces
crédits supplémentaires permettront de
renouveler et de renforcer notre flotte
d'hélicoptère conformément
préconisations formulées l'année
dernière par la commission des lois
cette forte hausse nous apparaît
nécessaire et même vital dans l'année
2022 mise à rude épreuve tous les
acteurs de la sécurité civile avec 72000
hectares brûlés soit 7 fois la moyenne
des 20 dernières années la dernière
saison des feux a marqué une nette
rupture dans notre appréhension des
aléas remettant en question de
nombreuses certitudes quant à la
résilience de notre modèle de lutte
contre les incendies la réponse est ur
outre la réquisition précipitée de 8
hélicoptères la France qui
traditionnellement aide ses voisins a eu
recours pour la première fois depuis son
instauration en 2001 au mécanisme
européen de protection civile nous avons
donc incontestablement atteint les
limites capacitaires de nos forces de
sécurité civile c'est pourquoi notre
avis favorable ne s'apparente aucunement
à inquiétus à l'égard du gouvernement
tout d'abord nous insistons sur la forte
attente de notre part quant à la
publication par le gouvernement du
rapport sur le financement des services
départementaux et territoriaux
d'incendie et de secours demandés dans
le cadre de la loi matras en effet toute
réflexion générale sur les moyens de la
sécurité civile rendu nécessaire cette
année doit impérativement associé les
collectivités territoriales et se
pencher sur l'enjeu des financements des
10 mis en difficulté par l'ampleur de la
dernière saison des feux et ne disposant
pas des mêmes leviers financiers que les
tapouris répondent concernant les moyens
aériens nationaux nous avons émis de
vivre réserves quant aux effets
d'annonce autour du plan de
renouvellement et de renforcement des
Canadiens largement commenté par le
ministre de l'Intérieur à l'occasion de
la loopi puis décrit comme une nouveauté
lors du discours du président de la
République le 28 octobre dernier cela
fait en outre plus de trois ans que sont
attendus les deux canadairs devant être
commandé dans le cadre de l'Union
européenne mais pourtant mis en avant
dans tous les discours gouvernementaux
sur la sécurité civile par ailleurs le
calendrier ambitieux affiché par le
Président de la République visant à
renouvellement intégral de nos canadairs
d'ici la fin du quinquennat apparaît
irréaliste alors qu'aucun financement
n'a encore été dégagé et démontre une
certaine confusion dans la communication
gouvernementale à deux reprises en effet
le Ministre de l'Intérieur a déclaré à
notre commission qu'il y avait de fortes
tensions sur la chaîne de production des
Canadairs et que ceux-ci devront se
faire attendre plusieurs années même en
faisant preuve d'optimisme nous serons
nous serons donc particulièrement
vigilants à ce que les annonces faites
soient convenablement menées à bien je
vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
dans la discussion générale longue que
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que la
discussion générale vaut l'explication
de vote la parole est à François Noël
buffet pour les républicains pour 12
minutes
la ministre chers collègues messieurs
les rapporteurs quelques observations
pour le compte du groupe les
républicains en réalité 4 la première
c'est que il y a plusieurs années déjà
que le Sénat appelait de ses vœux une
loi de programmation pour la sécurité
pour information la commission Miss
Paritaire aura lieu jeudi prochain
quelques points de vigilance c'est
quelques points positifs 6 points de
vigilance le premier d'entre eux c'est
naturellement la nécessité de fortifier
dans la durée des capacités
opérationnelles des forces de sécurité
intérieure mais c'est aussi de
considérer que ces efforts doivent
impérativement se poursuivre madame la
ministre jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
enfin retenir que nous avons au contenu
des deux grands événements sportifs à
venir la Coupe du monde de rugby mais
aussi les Jeux olympiques de 2024 des
moyens importants à déployer qui devront
être fait évidemment en bonne et du
forme mais surtout sur lequel nous
devrons pas renier naturellement en
termes de sécurité rappelez aussi quand
même que l'augmentation des effectifs ne
devra pas se faire aux dépens des
dépenses d'investissement et de
fonctionnement c'est assez me
semble-t-il important c'est la déjà été
souligné d'ailleurs par notre collègue
Dominati il y a quelques instants donc
cela pour conséquence d'avoir une
prudence quotidienne quotidienne
peut-être pas mais en tous les cas une
vigilance particulière quant à
l'affectation de ces crédits faut-il
râper naturellement que le contexte
budgétaire de notre pays est extrêmement
contraint et que d'ailleurs le Conseil
d'État avait mis des réserves en tous
les cas des inquiétudes sur deux avis
concernant cette locmin les points
positifs il y en a trois d'abord la
dernière loi de programmation sur les
moyens du ministère intérieur datent un
peu elle était pour la période 2011 2013
c'est vrai que nous aurions préféré
avoir une loopmie beaucoup plus
rapidement mais elle est là
tant mieux dire aussi que cette hausse
de 15 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
budgetés sur cinq ans et bien il faut
bien l'admettre est un effort
substantiel le deuxième point c'est un
budget qui ne doit pas être conjoncturel
mais qui doit être à l'inverse
structurel rien ne se répire pour nos
services de sécurité d'être les victimes
d'une politique
erratique d'abord plusieurs objectifs
plus réels doivent être retenues je
voudrais les rappeler le premier c'est
les crédits affectés à la police et à la
gendarmerie qui passerait d'environ 21
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
à plus de 25 milliards en 2027 c'est une
hausse conséquente puisqu'elle est de
plus de 20%. une hausse des dépenses de
personnel également à de 5,8% pour la
police et pour la gendarmerie une
annonce de même la première ministre le
6 septembre dernier de la création de
8500 postes de policiers et gendarmes
d'ici 2027 et une mise à niveau de nos
équipements acquisition de gilet
tactiques développement de solutions
opérationnelles comme le PC Storm pour
permettre aux forces de sécurité de
communiquer via un outil unique et
diriger dans l'attente du déploiement du
réseau radio du futur créé dans le pays
à qui chante caméra piéton et ainsi de
suite ce niveau d'équipement est
absolument essentiel et enfin rappelé la
montée en puissance des réserves
opérationnelles cela a été dit également
tout à l'heure de la police avec plus de
8 millions et demi d'euros en 2023 de la
gendarmerie pour plus de 14 millions
d'euros troisième point et en fait il
reste deux points évoqués qui sont deux
points particuliers
l'enjeu crucial du numérique
près de 8 milliards d'euros affectés au
numérique c'est quasiment la moitié du
budget total prévu par la locmie donc ce
qui n'est naturellement pas une petite
affaire si vous me permettez cette
expression il faut donc poursuivre le
développement des cas de nos capacités
numériques on a évoqué tout à l'heure
les terminaux néo les ordinateurs
portables bituti et beaucoup d'autres
développer pleinement aussi le dépôt de
plainte en ligne c'est un sujet qui a
déjà été abordé via le dispositif de pré
plainte mais là il faut quand même aller
beaucoup plus loin pour être encore plus
opérationnel enfin développer les
applications permettant d'accroître le
nombre d'actes de procédures que peuvent
réaliser nos policiers et nos gendarmes
en mobilité et pardon enfin éviter à
tout prix vraiment même la ministre
c'est important le fiasco du logiciel
scribe qui nous a posé quand même
quelques difficultés sur le plan
technologique c'est le deuxième point
après ce budget du milliard quid de
l'intelligence artificielle ça reste
aussi là un sujet essentiel il n'existe
pas à ce de cadre juridique adapté à
l'usage des technologies de
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public
pourtant pourtant une mission
d'information du Sénat portée par nos
collègues Marc-Philippe de Bresse Arnaud
de Bellay Jérôme Durand a rendu un
rapport le 10 mai dernier sur 30
propositions pour écarter le risque
d'une société sous surveillance je pense
que c'est une source en tous les cas qui
peut vous être largement
utile en prévision des événements qui du
grand événement sportif notamment mais
pas seulement d'ailleurs les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 on doit être prêt à
créer ce cadre adapté en fixant
naturellement et nous rapporteurs l'ont
fait des lignes rouges qui ne peuvent
être bien sûr franchis quatrième point
et ce sera le dernier c'est la question
sensible de la réforme de la police
judiciaire
nous les votons pas suffisamment en tous
les cas il y a une mission au sein de la
commission des lois qui est en cours
mais à l'occasion de se débat budgétaire
le groupe qu'elle fait appartient
vaudrait quand même rappeler que il y a
au cœur de la police judiciaire de la
des réformes une crise évocation
cela est constaté partagé partout que
c'est des difficultés de recrutement ne
sont pas liées d'ailleurs au désintérêt
pour ces fonctions mais aux conditions
de travail et aux difficultés de ces
conditions de travail il faut bien
reconnaître que l'ensemble de nos
personnels de police servant dans le
cadre de la préjudiciaire sont
disponibles 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 des conditions d'exercice de la
profession compte tenu des enjeux qui
sont les leurs et qui sont les nôtres
tout à fait exceptionnels c'est donc une
grande spécificité de ce métier on
voudrait donc profiter de l'occasion de
ce débat pour rappeler que alors que les
discussions s'ouvrent sur la
réorganisation de la prise judiciaire
le point particulier soit vraiment un
point de vigilance il y a une vraie
question d'évocation il faut vraiment
poser les problèmes sérieusement sur la
table pour que notre police judiciaire
qui est un exemple il faut bien le dire
puisse continuer d'exercer dans
l'excellence l'excellence étant de
poursuivre les voyous dans les
infractions les plus graves enfin pour
conclure
ce que je voudrais vous dire ce que les
efforts sont là
point particulier là encore vigilance
l'efficacité de notre sécurité des
moyens qui seront mis en place vont ou
va avec la continuité de la chaîne
pénale c'est-à-dire les moyens qui
seront donnés la justice pour apporter
des réponses bien sûr aux opérations qui
seront menées par nos services de
sécurité mais nous verrons le sujet
justice cet après-midi en tous les cas
n'oublions pas que c'est quand même un
ensemble qu'il faut faire fonctionner
deuxième chose c'est que le doublement
effectifs sur la voie publique n'a de
sens que si nos effectifs décès
judiciaires qui traitent les enquêtes et
une prédictions sont également
augmentées proportionnellement il y a un
lien direct chacun le comprend bien et
c'est la raison pour laquelle au
bénéfice de ces explications que nous
voulions rapides le groupe les
républicains suivra les avis favorables
du rapporteur général Monsieur David et
de nos deux rapporteurs pour avis
monsieur Henri Leroy et Madame Françoise
Dumont et la courtoisie aurait voulu
madame que je vous cite en premier je
vous prie de mon excuser merci
merci
monsieur le Président
la parole est à Monsieur Alain Marc pour
le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mais mes chers collègues le
budget que nous examinons aujourd'hui
reprend les éléments de la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur voté il y a peu
cette loi de programmation prévoit une
augmentation des moyens consacrés à nos
forces de l'ordre la progression de
l'insécurité doit en effet être enrayé
c'est le jouet certes du président de la
République mais aussi je crois de tous
les citoyens de ce pays nous souhaitons
accroître la présence policière sur le
terrain nous sualluons bien entendu cet
engagement pour se faire il est
nécessaire de libérer les agents des
nombreuses tâches administratives
auxquelles ils sont astreints la Love Me
Y concours
il sera cependant nécessaire d'envisager
une réforme en profondeur de la
procédure pénale afin de la simplifier
tous les acteurs du monde judiciaire en
bénéficieront et les justiciables au
premier chef pour accroître cette
présence il faut aussi augmenter les
effectifs c'est notamment ce que prévoit
les crédits de cette mission entre 2017
et 2022 puis de 8000 policiers et plus
de 2000 gendarmes ont été recrutés 10
000 agents pardon supplémentaires
veillent donc à la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et de nos entreprises ainsi
qu'à la sûreté de nos territoires cette
dynamique se poursuit c'est un nez
encore nous nous en félicitons pour
créer de 3000 emplois seront créés en
en plus d'une augmentation d'effectifs
nos forces de l'ordre ont besoin
d'investissement massifs dont en matière
d'équipement qu'en matière d’immobilier
les policiers et gendarmes exerce un
métier dangereux dans des conditions
difficiles étendues à cet égard ils
doivent pouvoir compter sur un matériel
de qualité la question du parc
automobile est un sujet sensible même si
l'on peut constater ces dernières années
que cela s'est considérablement amélioré
on ne peut plus passer entre les
brigades de gendarmes et des gendarmes
qui se promènent en vieille Twingo ça
est un petit peu derrière nous et c'est
vraiment heureux parce que ça donne
quand même une autre image de nos forces
de l'ordre nous sommes quand même
préoccupés par la baisse des crédits
consacrés à son renouvellement
les délits de suite sont de plus en plus
nombreux et génèrent de plus en plus de
dégâts force doit rester à la loi les
policiers et les gendarmes doivent être
en mesure de maîtriser les suspects ils
ont pour cela besoin de véhicules
puissants fiables et donc récent même si
comme je dis des efforts ont été faits
le parc immobilier a lui aussi grand
besoin d'être rénové et modernisé la
dynamique est enclenchée il convient de
la maintenir cet effort dans la durée
l'émission des forces de l'ordre évolue
sans cesse à mesure que le numérique
prend une place de plus en plus
importante dans nos vies la délinquance
le crime s'y développe nos policiers et
gendarmes doivent acquérir de nouvelles
compétences et de nouvelles capacités
pour y faire face et assurer la sécurité
de nos concitoyens nous avons tous en
tête les récentes attaques informatiques
qui ont ciblé les hôpitaux ou encore des
communes leur complexité et leur impact
ne cessent de croître parallèlement
de récentes arrestations ont mis au jour
d'importants réseaux pédopornographique
dans notre pays tout cela démontre
l'ampleur prise par le numérique dans le
travail des forces de l'ordre l'alomi
prévoit en conséquence un plan de
modernisation numérique particulièrement
nécessaire et attendu au-delà de ces
nouveaux champs d'intervention policiers
et gendarmes assurent également des
missions plus classiques mais tout aussi
importantes il s'agit par exemple de la
sécurité routière ce sujet n'avait pas
les gros titres des journaux mais il
emporte chaque année la vie de plus de
3000 de nos concitoyens c'est à dire
trois fois plus que le nombre
d'homicides l'augmentation des crédits
dédiés à la sécurité routière et donc
bienvenue d'autant plus que 2022 semble
être une année particulièrement mauvaise
à cet égard il faut inverser la tendance
l'accroissement des missions
l'augmentation de la délinquance de la
criminalité justifie l'augmentation du
budget consacré à la sécurité nos
concitoyens ont besoin de sécurité pour
pouvoir exercer
leur liberté notre groupe votera donc en
faveur de l'adoption de ce budget merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Thomas dessus pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur et rapporteur
pour avis mes chers collègues
première traduction financière de la
loopmie portée par ce gouvernement le
budget de la mission sécurité voit les
crédits à louer à ce volet de l'action
publique fortement augmentée on doit
s'en réjouir mais nous ne sommes pas là
pour ne regarder que le chiffre en bas
du tableau c'est bien la répartition et
l'utilisation de ces fonds qui interroge
notre groupe
lors des longs débats que nous avons eu
autour de la loopy nous avons pu exposer
notre vision des forces de l'ordre au
service des citoyens et au plus proche
d'eux lors de cet examen nous avons bien
voté l'article de la trajectoire
d'augmentation des crédits alloués au
serviteurs de l'État et nous saluons
aussi les forces substantielles pour
reprendre les termes du président buffet
qui en décrivait l'usage
mais pas le rapport par exemple qui ont
décrivait l'usage
les forces de sécurité de notre pays
sont parfois au même titre que d'autres
fonctionnaires comme les soignants de
l'hôpital public les enseignants ou les
magistrats bien maltraités par l'État
employeur ce sentiment d'abandon de
manque de moyens d'accompagnement de
formation aggravée par les politiques du
chiffre et des missions aussi
chronophages qui n'utilisent se traduit
hélas par un épuisement de nos forces de
l'ordre
24% des gendarmes ou policiers déclarent
être confrontés à des pensées
suicidaires c'est cela qui devrait être
la priorité nous avons bien perçu la
continuité d'une politique qui se veut
plus répressive que protectrice qui
ignorent à la fois presque complètement
le lien de confiance à renforcer avec la
population mais aussi en même temps
cette immense souffrance au travail de
nos forces de l'ordre qui pourtant
s'engagent pour agir auprès de la
population avec la population pour la
population
ce gouvernement préfère allouer l'argent
public à une numérisation une
robotisation outrancière une
modernisation de façade qui oublie les
problèmes du quotidien à la fois des
citoyens et des agents la numérisation
ne simplifie pas ne simplifie la vie que
d'une partie de la population
l'électronisme est une réalité qui
touche 13 millions de personnes en
France ne les laissons pas à la porte de
nos services publics je profite d'être à
cette tribune pour m'associer au crâne
de bonnes gestion soulevées par de
nombreux parlementaires sur
l'investissement dans de la technologie
qui quand on voit le fiasco qui a pu
être le déploiement du logiciel scribe
alors certes dans l'autre côté la menace
numérique s'accroît nous nous
réjouissons du renforcement des services
de lutte contre la cybercriminalité nous
saluons ici l'ensemble des agents qui
ont récemment permis interpellation de
plusieurs cyberpedocrinels
nous saluons aussi l'engagement
gouvernemental de répondre enfin à la
vétusté des locaux qui n'est pas sans
conséquence à la fois pour les forces de
l'ordre mais aussi pour les gardes à vue
comme la très justement soulignée
Dominique Simoneau l'amélioration des
conditions digne de travail est
essentiel pour renforcer les liens
d'aujourd'hui avec les citoyens
nos craintes restent les mêmes depuis
l'étude de la loopy un développement de
façades d'une police structurée autour
du Tour et précif une multiplication des
nouvelles compagnies de CRS calibrées
nous dit-on pour faire face aux grands
événements que notre pays s'apprête à
accueillir mais sans repenser notre
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre qui a
pourtant brillé par sa médiocrité y
compris internationalement lors d'un
grand événement
l'évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'investissement entre
la police et la gendarmerie diffère
elles augmentent ainsi significativement
pour la police nationale mais diminue
pour la gendarmerie nationale nous
défendons une police de proximité
essentielle pour renouer le lien de
confiance avec les citoyens ce sont donc
bien les missions que l'on doit
questionner dans la location des moyens
le tour est précis la culture du chiffre
assez limite et ce budget est loin de
dresser ce constat pour ce qui a des
missions inutilement consommatrices de
force et de moyens l'exemple des moyens
alloués à la lutte contre le cannabis
est emblématique de l'impasse d'une
politique antidrogue inefficace malgré
tous les coups de filet les pointes
d'îles démontées toutes les amandes
forfaitaires ou vous heurtez toujours au
même problème les Français aiment se
produit en sont parmi les plus grands
consommateurs d'Europe votre politique
ne tient que par votre dogmatisme en
épuisant les troupes notre groupe
souhaite porter dans le budget la
transcription financière de propositions
que nous avions portées dans la loopmie
pour lesquelles nous avions eu le
soutien du gouvernement le développement
des officiers de liaison LGBT Qi ou
encore pour la formation au tir nous
porterons aussi la mise en oeuvre d'une
réelle autorité administrative
indépendante en charge de la déontologie
de nos forces de l'ordre sur le volet
sécurité civile notre déception est
grande comme partout ailleurs au
gouvernement les moyens ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux liés au changement
climatique qui ne permettent pas de
construire une première ligne solide
face au péril qui viennent
le budget la sécurité civile ne répond
pas selon nous aux besoins réels de
prévenir les risques accrus à venir ni
de compenser les dégâts subissent cet
été le renforcer le renforcement des
moyens de lutte contre les incendies et
bienvenus certes mais son niveau est
insuffisant dans un contexte
inflationniste
dans l'ensemble ce budget ne nous
convient pas et nous restons dubitatifs
au même titre que le Conseil d'État qui
a également déploré un manque de moyens
pour la situation de et l'évolution des
problèmes d'insécurité et de délinquance
au cours des dernières années ainsi
qu'une absence des évaluations des
dernières lois sécuritaires adoptées
2018 aussi notre groupe ne pourra pas
voter les crédits de cette mission je
vous remercie merci cher collègue la
parole est au président à la Richard de
pour le groupe RDP pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président et Madame la
Ministre m'excuse
je voudrais un peu de temps évoquer les
moyens croissants pour la police
nationale qui figure dans la voie de
programmation et qui connaissent une
première année de l'application avec des
créations d'emplois substantielles je
voudrais souligner que ça doit
s'accompagner c'est bien ce que prévoit
le projet de l'importance des actions de
formation à la fois initiale et continue
puisque la complexité des missions des
personnels leur polyvalence sont
évidemment au centre de la réussite de
même les efforts sur le numérique qui
sont un facteur à la fois dédicacité et
d'amélioration des conditions d'emplois
des personnels reste une priorité et il
faudra bien sûr tenir compte à maintenir
la prendre direction des difficultés
passées
en matière de politique de Ressources
Humaines je suis parmi ceux qui sont
attentifs évidemment aux problèmes de
d'attractivité des emplois policiers et
d'ailleurs aussi gendarmes dans les
grandes agglomérations naturellement
l'Île-de-France mais aussi les autres
les autres métropoles donc il faut à mon
avis continuer à chercher à renforcer
les outils de ces emplois parmi ceux que
j'entrevois il y a évidemment l'aide
dans le déroulement de carrière d'autant
plus que dans les commissariats dans les
services de sécurité civile de sécurité
publique pardon
des grandes agglomérations nos comptes
d'encadrant stable également donc je
crois que la gestion des carrières est
un levier efficace
mais il faudra aussi je pense en
particulier dans le contexte
Île-de-France réfléchir à des appuis au
besoin de logement des personnels
puisque c'est un des facteurs de retrait
je pourrais faire des observations
comparables pour la gendarmerie
nationale mais à propos du logement je
ferai une observation différente moi
j'ai connu quand j'avais la charge de la
gendarmerie à la défense une époque
bénie dans laquelle il y avait un accord
de fond entre les collectivités
principalement les départements et
la gendarmerie nationale pour assurer
le financement capital des installations
et
la récupération de la recette par les
loyers
ceci c'est dégradé parce que le prix des
installations de gendarmerie a cru très
substantiellement dans les années qui
ont suivi et qui fait que l'équation
financière ne fonctionne plus il me
semble que c'est un petit défi pour le
ministère de travailler à une
standardisation une homogénéisation des
plans des locaux de gendarmerie de
manière que on fasse aux collectivités
investisseurs
l'économie d'une recherche de d'optimum
dans chaque projet alors que ce sont
forcément des choses qui peuvent être
standardisées
je ferai très bref sur l'amélioration de
la chaîne benale mais nous voyons bien
qu'à l'heure actuelle en sécurité
publique et même en police judiciaire il
y a un découragement du fait du nombre
d'infractions qui n'ont pas encore pu
donner lieu à une
à une un travail judiciaire à une
enquête judiciaire
structurée et encore moins à une
décision de sanction et il faut
absolument que vous poursuiviez la
concertation avec la chancellerie de
manière que nous ayons une chaîne pénale
qui retrouve sa son efficacité mais je
voudrais puisque ces missions portent
les titres de sécurité au pluriel avec
un poète faire des observations en
matière de sécurité routière
nous avons connu des progrès réguliers
quant à la dangerosité de la circulation
au cours de la décennie passée mais ces
progrès tendent à se freiner et les
gendarmes font marquer dans les
départements à l'heure actuelle la
reprise de comportement vraiment
dangereux de
dépassement
sans visibilité de
vitesse importante etc donc je crois que
le besoin de surveillance et besoin de
purification aussi par les radars reste
une priorité mais je voudrais faire une
demande particulière au mystère de
l'intérieur dans sa permanence car je
suis absolument
dans l'incompréhension sur le la
nonimatriculation d'un très grand nombre
de véhicules lorsque nous avons en face
de nous des situations de rodéo
difficiles à réprimer nous observons que
certains véhicules de roues motorisés
sont immatriculées et que d'autres qui
sont censés être des véhicules tout
terrain ne sont pas immatriculés et
surtout ce qui m'inquiète c'est que dans
les nouvelles mobilités urbaines vous
voyez arriver toute une série de
catégories de véhicules qui sont
porteurs d'un certain nombre de
performance
et moi il m'est arrivé en rentrant du
Val d'oiseaux faire doubler à 45 km/h
par une trottinette dont le conducteur
était sans casque donc et quand je vois
aussi le fonctionnement des vélos qui
sont des véhicules assez lourds qui
frôlent les trottoirs il me semble qu'il
y a des précautions à prendre et donc je
voudrais madame la ministre que le
ministère de l'Intérieur se rende compte
que si on veut assurer un minimum de
respect de la loi dans la circulation
urbaine il y a une chose toute simple à
faire qui est d'immatriculer tous ces
véhicules j'observe une visionnera après
hier soir qu'une première compagnie de
location de trottinette a décidé de le
faire de sa propre initiative
franchement ça signifie que l'État à mon
avis allait se passer un train
merci chers collègues
la parole est au président Patrick
Kanner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain pour 9 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain est exigeant en
termes de moyens loué pour assurer à nos
concitoyens tous nos concitoyens des
sécurités leur sécurité je dirais même
leur sûreté finalement
cette mission qui regroupe les crédits
de la police nationale la gendarmerie
des pompiers étant hausse de 6,6% pour
2023 contact conformément à la
trajectoire contenue dans le projet de
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui a animé
beaucoup de nos débats il y a quelques
semaines si l'on peut s'en féliciter
bien sûr de cette hausse globale du
budget de la mission certaines
disparités sont néanmoins à noter par
exemple pour la police nationale trois
des six actions sont en baisse au nom et
non des moindres crédit à louer à la
sécurité et à la paix publique la
sécurité la gouttières on vient
d'évoquer les missions de police
judiciaire et concours de la justice
cibis toutes des baisses de plus de 13%.
pourtant la sécurité et la paix publique
ne sont pas à mettre sur un côté de
notre politique de sûreté nationale ce
signal est d'autant plus mauvais à un
moment où la réforme de la police
judiciaire est en question ça a été
évoqué par plusieurs de nos collègues
cela soulève beaucoup d'interrogations
dans la profession et c'est une des
difficultés qui est pressentie les
effectifs de la police de la police
judiciaire pardon ne doivent pas être
noyés par les affaires de délinquance
courantes c'est tout le débat que nous
aurons prochainement je n'en doute pas
vous rappelez sans doute les craintes
que nous avons pu exprimer pendant le
débat sur la locmi elle reste
d'actualité et les auditions que nous
suivons les uns les autres montrent que
les choses ne sont pas aussi simple que
parfois le ministre de l'Intérieur
voudrait nous les présenter
trois audites commandées par Monsieur
Darmanin et le garde des sceaux n'ont
pas encore produit leur résultat alors
ces travaux devraient je l'espère être
utile pour assurer la police judiciaire
partout sur notre territoire national
cette mission j'y reviens du projet de
loi de finances pour 2023 était donc
fortement lié au projet de la loopy et
nous avons été constructifs au nom de
mon groupe je vous rappellerai pas notre
vote mais il a été positif et si nous
sommes prêts à soutenir bien évidemment
toutes nos forces de l'ordre et nos
forces de sécurité civile nous n'en
sommes pas moins exigeants et notamment
sur quelques points précis notre
collègue le sénateur du Rhin qui porte
pour notre groupe c'est problématiques
là d'ailleurs répété à plusieurs
reprises notre vote ne signifie pas une
adhésion sans réserve et nous avons
entendu les voix qui nous disaient que
seuls la rationalisation budgétaire
avait pu guider cette réforme nous
serons donc vigilants chaque année à la
bonne application du projet de Love Me
qui donne des moyens insufflémentaires à
nos forces de sécurité mais nous nous
attachons également à ce que la réforme
de la police judiciaire ne conduisent
pas de nouvelles difficultés de
résolution des affaires résolution des
affaires auxquelles on droit nos
concitoyens en ce qui concerne la
gendarmerie la loi de programmation
sanctuarise la dynamique ascendante de
ces crédits tant mieux le renforcement
des moyens de la police la gendarmerie
se traduit par la poursuite des
regroupements avec dès l'année prochaine
l'accroissement d'effectifs 2857
[Musique]
notre groupe donc présentera
tout à l'heure plusieurs amendements
visant à étendre le bouclier tarifaire
par exemple
OS 10
comme les 10 ne seraient pas
bénéficiaires du tarifaire ils ont aussi
des dépenses aujourd'hui contraintes
notamment par les phénomènes de
l'inflation nous voudrions aussi
augmenter les moyens de la dotation de
soutien aux investissements structurants
il y a une meilleure protection contre
les agressions que les personnels
subissent c'est un sujet qui est
récurrent nous le savons et la
fédération nationale les
sapeurs-pompiers nous demande vraiment
une prise en considération de cette
problématique qui est évoquée à de
nombreuses reprises et malheureusement
l'actualité nous montre que très
régulièrement des sapeurs-pompiers sont
aujourd'hui agressés dans le cadre de
leur fonction y compris d'ailleurs par
les personnes qui sont amenées à
protéger
les grands défis auxquels les pompiers
doivent faire face du fait du
dérèglement climatique nécessite donc
qu'on leur accorde des moyens à la
hauteur de leur mission enfin quant au
crédit dédié à la sécurité à l'éducation
routière l'augmentation est surtout due
à l'intégration de nouvelles actions
jusqu'ici comprises dans d'autres
programmes en effet cette hausse semble
liée à l'augmentation des moyens de la
NTS rendu nécessaire par la
généralisation des amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles les fameuses AFD prévues
dans la locmi une mesure à laquelle nous
nous opposons nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire et le répétant les
AFD ne doivent pas être généralisées une
telle mesure méconner le principe
d'égalité devant la justice et entaché
d'incompétence négatives c'est au
législateur nous le demandons qu'il
appartient d'apprécier au cas par cas et
dans le respect de ce principe la
pertinence du recours à cette procédure
au regard de la conciliation à opérer
entre la nature du délit concerné la
protection des droits des personnes
mises en cause et les victimes la
défense des intérêts de la société les
exigences dans une bonne administration
de la justice que d'une répression
effective des infractions doivent
conduire notre parcours législatif vous
le voyez nous avons des réserves mes
chers collègues le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicains les exprime
régulièrement restera vigilant
naturellement sur les moyens mis en
œuvre mais
souhaitons pas être vous le savez une
opposition stérile et en pensant avant
tout avant tout à nos forces de sécurité
notre groupe votre a pour les crédits
d'évoluent à cette mission en conformité
avec les avis de nos rapporteurs que je
tiens à saluer je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président la parole est à la
présidente Eliana Sassi pour le groupe
CRCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues 2023 constituera
donc la première année de mise en oeuvre
de la loi de programmation et
d'orientation du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc les crédits du budget
sécurité accompagneront donc les
premières mesures de celle-ci alors je
crois que nous l'avons déjà souligné à
l'occasion de son examen au Sénat et je
me permets de leur réaffirmer ici la
locmi et la pierre angulaire d'une
police qui s'éloigne selon nous du
triptyque prévention dissuasion
répression une doctrine essentielle à
nos yeux par une approche en mode
dégradée de la police et de la sécurité
la locmi consacrera un relâchement du
lien de confiance entre les policiers et
la population elle est aussi
annonciatrice de ce que l'on peut déjà
considérer comme une perte de sens des
métiers de la sécurité alors loin de moi
de diaboliser la dématérialisation ou de
sous-est ça nécessitait voir son utilité
pour accéder à des informations et à des
démarches administratives mais selon moi
elle ne peut pas être l'alpha et l'oméga
de la relation entre la police et nos
concitoyens sur le fond on doit
s'interroger pour revisiter la doctrine
du maintien de l'ordre dans toute sa
dimension avec une priorité me
semble-t-il c'est celle de la formation
de nos forces de sécurité les lacunes de
la locmie que nous avions pointées lors
de son examen se traduisent aujourd'hui
dans le budget de la mission sécurité de
que nous ont que nous que nous examinons
les crédits de l'action sécurité
publique sont voués à concrétiser donc
l'opération l'entreprise de
dématérialisation des plaintes engagées
avec la loi de programmation Intel
affectation des crédits mettra toujours
selon nous à mal l'objectif d'une police
proche de nos concitoyens nous le
répétons l'efficacité ne doit pas rimer
avec une rupture du lien entre citoyens
et police de plus
les crédits de l'action mission de
police judiciaire et concours à la
justice qui rassemble l'ensemble des
activités de police judiciaires et des
missions réalisées au profit de la
justice ou de l'administration
pénitentiaire recule de 429 millions
d'euros sans que les documents
budgétaires n'offrent d'explications
alors même que c'est ce budget que ce
budget nous est présenté comme bouée
justement à resserrer j'insiste les
liens entre la police et les citoyens et
donc nous peinons à croire que par une
telle baisse des crédits alloués à la
police judiciaires nous poursuivons un
noble but
mais
objectivement je vous le dis ce n'est
donc pas le cas ce budget relatif aux
sécurité est un budget d'affichage car
sur le fond lorsque nous le décortiquons
il est aux antipodes d'un véritable
soutien à nos agents si un tel soutien
avait été octroyé le budget de la
formation de nos agents de police ne
seraient pas passer à la trappe ce
budget à la baisse de la police
judiciaire consolide notre analyse sur
la locmie son application sera lectrice
de perte de sens pour nos policiers je
vous rappelle madame la ministre que
nous manquons d'environ 5000 officiers
de police judiciaires nous peinons à
comprendre donc vos contradictions et je
dois dire nous nous inquiétons ici
l'image que nous donne le budget n'est
pas très attrayant de voir elle est
effrayante nous déduisons de son manque
d'envergure que la départementalisation
de la police nationale aura des
conséquences drastiques sur la police
judiciaire dénoncer tant par les
professionnels de la autorité mais
également par ceux de la justice cette
départementalisation sera synonyme
d'intrusion du pouvoir exécuté dans les
procédures pénales et vous nous donnez
la preuve par ce budget qu'à l'engendre
drap qu'elle engendrera également la
mutualisation des moyens pour ses
missions publiques une mutualisation que
l'on ne peut que déplorer car elle
dégradera les conditions de travail des
personnels auxquels je suis très
attachée et aussi aux conditions
d'accueil des victimes nous regrettons
également qu'à l'occasion de la tenue en
France de la Coupe du monde de rugby
2023 et des JO et des Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques de 2024 le budget n'est
pour lindemir qu'un objectif de quantité
et non de qualité nous nous posons la
question et ce n'est pas nouveau du
recours à des entreprises privées pour
assurer la sécurité des événements et
nous persistons à faire valoir que la
sécurité publique et du ressort du
pouvoir régalien et que les
fonctionnaires de police et de
gendarmerie sont des acteurs du service
public la privatisation n'est pas une
solution elle malmènera les conditions
de travail de nos forces de l'ordre et
ne sera pas encadré par la déontologie
qui justement encadre l'exercice des
fonctions régaliennes ainsi ce budget ne
fait que confirmer nos craintes je les
lis sur la locmi et en toute cohérence
nous ne voterons pas le budget pour la
mission en sécurité mais je dois dire
que nous serons attentifs à un certain
nombre d'amendements qui ont été déposés
par des collègues je vous remercie merci
madame la Présidente la parole est à
Madame Nathalie Goulet pour le groupe
unocentriste pour 8 minutes
la ministre mes chers collègues le
budget sécurité comporte quatre
programmes tout le monde le sait le
budget c'est une marque de volonté nous
l'avons vu déjà lors de la loopmie avec
une augmentation globale des crédits de
1,55 milliards pour l'ensemble des
missions sécurité la discussion
budgétaire c'est aussi le moyen
d'évoquer en dehors des chiffres des
stratégies alors je voudrais d'abord
vous interroger sur la cybercriminalité
et par ricochet aussi sur la coopération
internationale Sophie erreur de ma part
je n'ai pas lu dans les documents
budgétaires du programme des montants
liés à la coopération internationale qui
est pourtant totalement indispensable
certes il y a une contribution à
Interpol sur ce sujet et sur les
questions de terrorisme j'ai eu la
chance grâce au président buffet d'aller
passer une matinée
Interpol à Lyon
comprend évidemment hommage au travail
de cette organisation et à nos agents
qui sont détachés mais de quel moyen
disposez-vous Madame le Ministre pour
pour la coopération internationale pas
seulement aux frontières qui dépend
évidemment d'une autre mission mais
aussi dans la lutte contre la
cybercriminalité qui est évidemment pas
une lutte franco-française on ne compte
plus les cyberattaques la filière cyber
a été renforcée par l'augmentation du
nombre de gendarmes et policiers cyber
patrouilleurs avec la création du Centre
national de formation cyber CNF cyber
qui assurera la formation continue des
enquêteurs spécialisés et évidemment
c'est indispensable Tracfin a également
développé une cellule spécifique dédiée
à la délinquance financière liée aux
crypto actifs et je pense la ministre
que sur ce sujet il faut y mettre des
moyens extrêmement importants parce
qu'on est dans la guerre de l'obus et du
blindage et évidemment les délinquants
courent plus vite que la police c'est
une constante le 23 novembre dernier le
Parlement européen a été attaqué par une
attaque informatique après le vote sur
la Russie et je ne parle pas des traits
désagréables espionnage de nos amis du
Qatar tout ça n'est pas très rassurant
non plus pour la sécurité de nos
institutions vous avez
la ministre
je voudrais vous interroger également
sur
la position du ministre de l'économie et
des finances vous allez me renvoyer vers
lui en réalité mon intervention a été
pour Gérard dalmanin à qui j'ai indiqué
qu'il avait été récemment ministre du
Budget d'où mon hésitation à reprendre
le fil de mon intervention parce que le
ministre de l'économie est des finances
le 17 octobre dernier a indiqué qu'il
voulait que la France soit le camp de
base en Europe des crypto actifs
alors je sais pas s'il a failli de FTX
rafraîchi ces élans mais à la ministre
il va bien falloir préparer nos équipes
à ce qui va se passer si jamais et il
est absolument évident que l'usage des
crypto actifs va se développer et donc
non seulement notre connaissance du
sujet n'est pas parfaite c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire mais en plus on a une
directive européenne Mika qui va arriver
sur un encadrement de ces crypto actifs
donc il va vraiment falloir préparer nos
services à une une attaque en masse sur
ce type de délinquance ça ça me semble
tout à fait évident aujourd'hui
seulement 8% des Français détiennent des
crypto actifs mais ce pourcentage
augmente de façon exponentielle c'était
la première partie pour revenir à un
sujet plus plus local je voudrais vous
parler maintenant de la défense incendie
la question de la gestion du risque
incendie de remarque la première tient à
une nouvelle réglementation que nous
avons certes votée en matière de la
défense incendie et qui interdit dans
certains territoires purement et
simplement la moindre construction les
départements n'ayant pas les moyens des
infrastructures nécessaires un rapport
de la délégation collectivité du Sénat
estime que la réforme engagée en 2011 de
la défense extérieure contre l'incendie
n'a pas tenu ses promesses a provoquer
un large mécontentement de la part des
mères 70 % des mers interrogées par la
délégation estime que la concentration
n'a pas été suffisante 80% considèrent
que leur territoire n'est que
partiellement couvert au regard des
nouvelles normes de défense cela
signifie que après d'une habitation sur
trois serait hors champ de couverture
avec 6 à 7 millions de concitoyens
concernés les coûts de mise aux normes
sont astronomiques et insupportables le
département de l'Orne et sont 10
on t'imaginé dans ce contexte une
expérimentation que je vais vous narrer
il s'agit en l'espèce d'équiper de le 10
de 8 porteurs d'eau à forte capacité qui
permettrait donc d'équiper l'ensemble du
département dans un périmètre acceptable
et donc j'ai déposé sur ce dossier un
amendement pour une expérimentation
assez bon marché à peu près 2 millions
d'euros mais ça nous permettra d'évoquer
ce sujet plus longuement lors de la
discussion des articles mais sur cette
question des incendies j'ai quand même
été assez étonné que dans la première
partie de la loi de finances de nombreux
amendements de notre collègue
Anne-Catherine Loisier excellente
spécialiste de la question liée à la
forêt était repoussée en effet j'ai le
sentiment que la gestion des espaces
forestiers et risques incendie sont liés
intrinsèquement et que la question
budgétaire liée aux avantages des uns et
des autres pour notamment l'entretien
fait de ce matériel il a écrit au
Président de la République il a écrit
absolument à tout les services et le
moment est venu de vous faire la demande
directement au lendemain du congrès des
maires je pense que ça lui fera plaisir
si vous pouviez examiner sa demande de
très près j'utilise la première la
dernière minute qu'il me reste sur un
sujet tout à fait différent monsieur le
président
voilà cela pour vous dire précisément
qu'à la suite du Congrès des mères je
voudrais remercier l'ensemble des
personnels du Sénat qui ont assuré la
visite de centaines de personnes dans
des conditions tout à fait
exceptionnelles et que je voulais leur
rendre à ce moment précis un hommage
appuyé je vous remercie mais un
président merci pour eux et pour elle
chers collègues la parole est à Maryse
Carrère du groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues dans son Discours
sur l'origine et les fondements de
l'inégalité Jean-Jacques Rousseau nous
livre une bonne formule à mesure que le
genre humain s'étendit les peines se
multiplièrent je dirais que cette
multiplication des inquiétudes et des
dangers résonne bien avec le pull Uriel
employé pour cette mission dont les
enjeux sont singulièrement variés il y a
un premier lieu la sécurité quotidienne
celle de la vie ordinaire de nos
concitoyens celle des rues et des lieux
publics et qui vient avec ces procédures
que chacun était là ça menait à
rencontrer
les statistiques récentes en matière de
délinquance ne sont malheureusement pas
très encourageantes il y a ensuite la
sécurité événementielle la réception de
la finale de la Ligue des champions au
mois de juin dernier nous l'a bien
rappelé de ce point de vue nous abordons
des années décisives avec l'approche de
deux événements phares la Coupe du monde
de rugby et les Jeux Olympiques enfin il
y a la sécurité de crise et je pense en
particulier aux incendies de cet été qui
ont durement frappé la Gironde voici
donc autant de moments durant lesquels
des agents doivent être mobilisés sans
discontinuer nous avons examiné au mois
d'octobre la loopmie qui affiche de
nombreuses promesses et ce budget me
semble aller dans la direction annoncée
la hausse d'un milliard d'un milliard
n'a rien de négligeable elle vient avec
un certain nombre de recrutements
attendus tant du côté de la police que
de la gendarmerie
je crois que nous aurions tort de nous
montrer trop pessimiste d'autant que
cette cette progression poursuit celle
déjà observée au cours des exercices
précédents
pêle-mêle voici quelques points que nous
souhaitons saluer la trajectoire de
hausse des dépenses de personnel
constatées sur les précédents budget
d'environ 6%, je l'ai déjà évoqué mais
je me réjouis de cette importante des
effectifs de la police et de la
gendarmerie nationale autre point la
dynamique maintenue des dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'investissement cela
devrait accompagner les recrutements
afin de permettre aux agents d'être
opérationnel d'un point de vue matériel
là aussi c'est une bonne chose ensuite
l'affectation de crédit en vue de
développer les outils de lutte contre
les cybercriminalités il ne faut
nullement le négliger le piratage au
cours de l'été du réseau informatique de
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes a très
bien rappelé la nécessité de poursuivre
l'investissement dans ce domaine
enfin je ne peux que souligner les
crédits qui devraient être alloués au
renouvellement de la flotte
d'hélicoptère nous le voyons donc pour
toutes ces missions de sécurité publique
il faut des agents et du matériel un
nombre suffisant et en plus de la
quantité il faut de la qualité c'est à
dire des agents correctement formés
c'est un aspect sur lequel le groupe
RDSE a déjà eu l'occasion d'insister en
particulier lors de l'examen de la loop
me je le redis qu'il s'agisse de la
formation initiale comme de la formation
continue qui est trop souvent délaissé
au cours de la carrière il y a encore à
faire si nous souhaitons améliorer la
performance des différents services les
travaux en cours de la mission
d'information sur les moyens d'action
les méthodes d'intervention de la police
et de la gendarmerie que je rapporte
avec ma collègue de ma collègue
Catherine ni Folco nous révèle une marge
importante de progression à la matière
enfin il y a un point sur lequel pour
lequel nous avons tout de même souhaité
insister il s'agit des enjeux de
sécurité civile des cas sur la question
des incendies que j'évoquais
précédemment est un point
particulièrement préoccupant pour les
années à venir elle donne le sentiment
de n'être pas assez soutenu dans les
perspectives budgétaires d'autant que
les projections climatiques ne viennent
pas nous rassurer sur ce point aussi
notre groupe présentera plusieurs
amendements qui devraient participer à
encourager l'investissement dans la
lutte contre l'incendie je pense en
particulier à la proposition de notre
collègue Jean-Yves roux qui a pour
objectif d'accompagner financièrement
les communes rurales dans la réalisation
de leurs obligations légales de
débroussaillement ou bien l'amendement
de Nathalie Delattre visant à donner des
moyens financiers nécessaires à
l'acquisition de drones utile à la lutte
contre les incendies
ces remarques faites notre groupe
devrait voter en faveur des crédits
accordés à cette mission je vous
remercie si chers collègues et pour
clore cette discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Caroline Cayeux
cailleux ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales pour 15
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je représente pour l'examen de
ce texte le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer qui ne peut
malheureusement pas être présent comme
il l'aurait souhaité en raison de son
déplacement à Bruxelles pour le Conseil
justice et à faire intérieur
la mission sécurité du projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 qui est soumise à
votre approbation est essentiel pour
tous les Françaises et les Français elle
déterminent les moyens mis à la
disposition de l'État pour lui permettre
d'assurer l'une de ces missions
premières garantir à chacun de nos
concitoyens son droit à mener une vie
tranquille dans notre pays sont droits à
y vivre en sécurité dans mon propos
j'espère messieurs les sénateurs que
vous trouverez quelques réponses aux
questions que vous avez soulevées
beaucoup pas été fait depuis 2017 sous
la conduite du président de la
République pour renforcer la sécurité
intérieure les efforts budgétaires
constants ont été consentis se
traduisant par exemple par le plan de
recrutement exceptionnel de 10000
policiers et gendarmes que nous avons
conduit ou encore par les crédits
conséquents qui ont été mobilisés dans
le cadre du plan de relance dirigé entre
autres sur la prise en compte des
nouveaux enjeux de la protection et
l'équipement de nos policiers de mais
c'est vrai beaucoup restent encore à
faire le caractère novateur l'ambition
et le pragmatisme de la politique que
nous souhaitons mener transparaissent
clairement je le crois dans la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour la période
2023 2027 et qui a d'ailleurs été adopté
par une large majorité ici au Sénat et
par l'Assemblée nationale récemment j'y
vois la mobilisation de tous pour
soutenir le renforcement de la sécurité
de notre pays
je voudrais souligner que le consensus
parlementaire qui s'est dégagé n'est pas
le fruit du hasard mais la conséquence
de la méthode que nous avons poursuivie
dans son élaboration celle de la
concertation et de la co-construction
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de la
sécurité intérieure de notre pays dans
le cadre notamment du beau veau de la
sécurité qui s'est achevé en octobre
dernier cette loi d'orientation est
programmation prévoit une hausse du
budget du ministère de 15 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans cette augmentation
historique n'est pas seulement
l'addition de moyens nouveaux elle est
mise en service elle est mise au service
d'une vision stratégique refondée de la
sécurité intérieure une vision
stratégique nouvelle que porte le PLF
pour 2023 première à nuité de la mise en
oeuvre de la locminie qui voit d'ores et
déjà une hausse du ministère de
l'Intérieur de 1 25 milliards d'euros
au travers du texte de la mission
sécurité en particulier nous nous
donnons les ressources nécessaires pour
intensifier et améliorer encore les
constantes de l'action publique notre
lutte contre la criminalité contre
toutes les formes de délinquance la
prévention des risques et la prise en
charge de nos concitoyens en danger cela
passe par le renforcement de nos
capacités opérationnelles et par
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
de l'ensemble des agents de la sécurité
intérieure mais nous nous donnons
également les moyens d'apporter une
réponse forte et adaptée au défi inédits
que la France traverse en ce moment dans
un contexte de multiplication des crises
à la fois géopolitique économique
sociale et environnementale autant de
menaces nouvelles pour nos concitoyens
qui risquent à terme si nous n'en
prenons pas la pleine mesure de
déstabiliser notre contrat social et de
mettre en péril la cohésion de la nation
la mission sécurité se décompose comme
vous le savez en quatre programmes
distincts qui recouvrent les différents
volets de l'action de l'État en matière
de sécurité intérieure en tout comme
dans chacune de ces parties la mission
sécurité porte un engagement financier
en aide augmentation par rapport à
l'année dernière au total le budget de
la mission est en hausse de
6,82% en autorisation d'engagement et de
6 65% en crédit de paiement par rapport
à 2022 je vais vous faire part des
lignes directrices qui ont été les
nôtres pour chacun de ces programmes
ainsi que de leur mesure principale
d'abord pour ce qui est de la police et
de la gendarmerie nationale l'objectif
premier est bien de répondre aux besoins
d'une présence accrue d'agents sur la
voie publique conformément d'ailleurs à
l'objectif fixé par le président de la
République dans doubler le nombre d'ici
10 ans
continuez à mettre plus d'agent sur le
terrain pour améliorer directement la
qualité de vie de nos concitoyens dans
tous les territoires en métropole comme
en outre-mer cela passe d'abord
nécessairement par la poursuite de notre
renforcement des effectifs de 2023 dès
2023 2857 équivalent temps plein seront
créés avec l'objectif d'atteindre près
de 7400 nouveaux policiers gendarmes
d'ici 5 ans il viendront armer en
particulier les 11 unités de force
mobile supplémentaires que nous voulons
créer d'ici les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 cet escadron de
gendarmerie mobile et 4 compagnies
républicaines de sécurité auxquelles
viendront s'ajouter les 7 unités de
force mobiles parisiennes libérée de
leur mission de garde statique
il viendront également renforcer les
circonscriptions de sécurité publique
prioritaires de la police nationale où
ils seront déployés en particulier sur
la voie publique et dans les transports
en commun le ministre a annoncé cette
semaine que les effectifs passeront de
1675 policiers et gendarmes à 3510 soit
1835 de plus dont 200 à Paris d'ailleurs
c'est un effort sans précédent en
parallèle nous allons accompagner la
montée en puissance de la réserve
opérationnelle de la police nationale et
de la gendarmerie avec l'objectif
d'atteindre 50000 réservistes d'ici 2027
ce budget spécifiquement consacré à la
réserve de la gendarmerie sera abondée
de 14 millions d'euros lui permettant
ainsi de renforcer ses effectifs de 6000
réservistes tandis que celui de la
réserve de la police sera abondé à
hauteur de 8 millions d'euros
de même nous poursuivrons la poursuite
de la substitution de personnels
opérationnelles par des personnels
civils administratifs et des corps
militaires de soutien permettant pour
2023 de libérer 900 policiers gendarmes
supplémentaires le PLF 2023 vise
également à donner les moyens
nécessaires au ministère de l'Intérieur
dans la perspective de la Coupe du monde
de rugby et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 concernant ces
derniers le ministre vous a présenté fin
octobre le dispositif détaillé de
sécurisation qu'il envisage pour cet
événement inédit près de 35000 policiers
et gendarmes qui seront mobilisés en
moyenne par jour et près de 200 millions
d'euros sont déjà identifiés dans notre
budget pour permettre de disposer des
moyens humains et matériels nécessaires
notre deuxième objectif concomitant et
d'affirmer d'infermir l'ancrage
territorial de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure pour résorber les zones
blanches sécuritaires qui pourraient
exister dans notre pays pour cela on
concertation avec les élus locaux nous
engageons la création de 200 nouvelles
brigades territoriales d'ici 2027 et
pour consolider cet engagement majeur
viendra s'ajouter la démétropolisation
de près de 300 postes
plus de policiers et de gendarmes donc
dans l'ensemble de notre pays mais
également des policiers et des gendarmes
mieux équipés en 2023 ce sont 4800
véhicules légers qui seront acquis par
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
nationale dans la continuité des efforts
fait ces dernières années mais également
près de 250 millions d'euros mobilisés
pour l'habillement et l'achat de tonus
spécialisée ainsi que l'équipement des
agents en particulier nous finaliserons
l'achat de caméra piétons pour atteindre
l'objectif de 54000 et ainsi renforcer
notre transparence sur l'action des
forces de l'ordre de même dès 2023 nous
engageons le développement du réseau
radio du futur avec 250 millions d'euros
dédiés sur près de 2 milliards d'euros
investis au total pour son déploiement
d'ici 2030 cette solution de
télécommunication résiliente et
interopérable est un atout indispensable
pour permettre à nos forces de sécurité
de gagner toujours en plus d'efficacité
je veux enfin souligner que 2023 sera
aussi l'année où nous lancerons
l'acquisition de 36 nouveaux
hélicoptères pour le ministère avec la
volonté de renouveler le parc existant
et également de l'harmoniser entre ces
différentes composantes gendarmes et
sécurité civile nous poursuivons
également le soutien au déploiement de
la vidéoprotection sur la voie publique
avec pas moins de 22 millions d'euros
programmés pour la seule année 2023
au-delà de la prise en charge de la
délinquance du quotidien les forces de
sécurité intérieure seront dotées de
moyens supplémentaires pour faire face
aux nouveaux enjeux dont elles doivent
s'emparer pleinement je cite la prise en
compte croissante des nouvelles
frontières de la délinquance en
particulier numérique la filière cyber
sera ainsi renforcée par le recrutement
de 1500 gendarmes et policiers cyber
patrouilleurs supplémentaires et le
développement d'un appel d'urgence le 17
cyber ou encore les enjeux
environnementaux avec le déploiement dès
l'année prochaine des premiers éléments
de la gendarmerie verte formée aux
atteintes de l'environnement et dotés
d'un commandement unique l'année 2023
amorcera également la première étape de
la mise en place des protocoles sociaux
liés à la mise en œuvre de la locmi qui
vise à améliorer de façon conséquente le
les conditions de travail de tous les
agents de la sécurité intérieure
avec des mesures d'aide en matière de
logement pour les policiers mais
également des aides à la garde d'enfants
en horaire atypique ainsi que les
premières revalorisations de grilles
indiciaires mais également
l'augmentation de certaines primes et
d'indemnités comme celle attribuées aux
officiers de police judiciaires
l'indemnité journalière d'absence
temporaire ou encore la prime pour le
travail de nuit des policiers
premier acte de la lochmie cette mission
sécurité vous le voyez mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'elle souligne
notre volonté d'engager régulièrement la
dynamique au service de nos forces de
sécurité et de la meilleure protection
nos concitoyens en particulier à
l'approche des grandes rendez-vous
sportifs et populaires que notre pays
accueillera dans les prochains mois
le même volontarisme se retrouve dans le
programme sécurité civile cette année
plus encore que les précédentes les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
se sont cruellement fait sortir sur
notre territoire je pense au feu de
forêt dévastateurs de cet été au ravage
de la tempête Fiona en Guadeloupe ou
encore aux fortes intempéries qu'on
connus la Somme et le Pas-de-Calais
récemment face à ces menaces d'ampleur
il est sûr que nous devons réarmer notre
sécurité civile pour lui permettre de
faire face à des crises toujours plus
complexes et inattendues dans les années
à venir
les objectifs déjà conséquents contenus
dans la première version du programme
161 seront encore augmentés par deux
amendements gouvernementaux afin
d'inclure les dernières mesures
annoncées par le Président de la
République en retour d'expérience de la
saison des feux de forêt un premier
amendement viendra ainsi ajouter 12
millions d'euros afin de renforcer les
moyens humains et matériels dédiés à la
lutte contre les feux de forêts tandis
qu'un second permettra de mobiliser 240
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et 24 millions d'euros en
crédit de paiement pour l'acquisition de
14 canadairs supplémentaires
ces deux amendements complètent celui
qui a été intégré dans le PLF 2023
issu de l'Assemblée nationale et portant
sur une augmentation des moyens dédiés
au pacte capacitaire au sein de la
dotation de soutien à l'investissement
structurant des 10 à hauteur des 150
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et de 37,5 millions d'euros
en crédit de paiement les engagements
pris dans le cadre de cette enveloppe
exceptionnelle ouverte en 2023 donneront
lieu à des paiements étalés au cours des
prochaines années au fur et à mesure du
déploiement des projets d'investissement
déployer avec les collectivités
territoriales au profit des 10 enfin
pour ce qui est du programme sécurité
routière les moyens mobilisés sont une
nouvelle fois en net hausse car si les
chiffres sont bons nous ne pouvons pas
nous permettre de relâcher nos efforts
le nombre de tués sur la route sur les
routes de France a continué de diminuer
en 2021 par rapport à 2019 dernière
année de référence sans restriction de
circulation avec une baisse de plus de 9
% pour pérenniser cet élan il faut bien
sûr continuer d'agir en termes de
dépistage en termes de formation avec le
recrutement d'inspecteur du permis de
conduire et de la sécurité routière
supplémentaire et surtout en termes de
prévention et de communication auprès de
nos concitoyens c'est une nouvelle fois
l'axe fort de ce programme pour cette
année 2023 avec une prise en compte
croissante de nouveaux facteurs
d'accidentalité comme les mobilités
douces mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous le voyez ce PLF pour 2023
et cette mission sécurité en particulier
donne aux forces de sécurité intérieure
les crédits indispensables pour
s'adapter aux nouveaux enjeux de notre
époque et renforcer
de protection pour tous les Français et
les françaises comme l'écrivait Henri
Fayolle prévoit c'est à la fois supputer
l'avenir et le préparer prévoir c'est
déjà agir c'est ce que cette mission va
permettre de faire c'est à vous
désormais mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qui appartient de la voter au
nom de l'intérêt général de notre pays
et de nos concitoyens je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
il restera cet après-midi à examiner les
amendements vous aurez à peu près une
heure pour le faire puisque la mission
l'examen de la mission est limitée à
deux heures et demie
voilà je vais suspendre l'assurance elle
sera reprise à 14h35 pour la suite de
l'examen des crédits de la mission
sécurité la séance est suspendue